you
our first stage will be to bring some
tissue from his forearm over here up
into here to reconstruct initial upper
and lower lips and then I'll be followed
by a second stage where we put little
balloons to expand his normal skin and
his cheeks
[Music]
we expect to get functioning lips for
him will they be his real lips no but
we're hoping they'll be lips that look
normal and allow him to heat properly
and speak properly
since the accident
he's been isolated was withdrawn refuses
to go to school has no friends so we're
hoping that after the surgery he'll
reintegrate into society perhaps go back
to school but at least have some
semblance of a normal life
you